hey what's up mkbhd here and these are
samsung's new 2022 flagship smartphones
and i'm saying it's these and not the
ultra just because these will probably
sell more volume and these are the
phones more people will experience
and i do have some thoughts for my first
hands-on with them so the running theme
i think you'll notice here is uh if it
ain't broke don't fix it
so they didn't they really did not
change a whole lot about these there's a
lot that's similar they played it safe
but one of the biggest differences one
of the most noticeable differences to me
when i actually got to hold it and feel
it in the hand is something that most
people who buy it probably won't care
about that much because everyone puts a
case on their phone and that's the build
quality so i have a video on the s22
ultra dropping at the exact same time as
this one it'll be linked below if you
want to watch that it's basically a
galaxy note but these phones are a small
update in every department from the s21
series across the board and like i said
holding it in the hand for the first
time the first thing i noticed is it's a
bit more boxy a little more square on
the sides a little more flat on the top
and the bottom and just slightly tighter
corner radii all the way around and the
display is already flat on the front so
it just feels a bit sharper overall and
then on top of that the back is real
glass this year instead of plastic like
the s21 again not a huge deal for most
people just putting a case on their
phone but that is a step up in my
opinion from the s21 and the s21 fv and
it adds a little bit of weight too it's
some density some heft to the feel of
the phone
everything else on the outside though
mostly the same design same center
camera cut out that i like so much same
speaker and button placement same
fingerprint reader placement still ip68
rated and at the front you're looking at
essentially the same display as last
year but slightly better and slightly
smaller so still two different sizes of
course the s22 plus is 6.6 inches
and this might sound weird to say but
because of how small the bezels are the
s22 at 6.1 inches feels kind of compact
now i'm doing air quotes like this isn't
this clearly isn't a small phone but the
new boxer shape and just the way it
feels with the smaller bezels and the
tighter corners it's it has a nice
density to it just feels like a good
compact sort of phone the update with
this display though is it is now a much
more variable refresh rate than last
year so instead of just being 60 or 120
hertz this goes from 10 all the way up
to 120 hertz now interestingly i'm told
from samsung it is still not ltpo that's
for the s22 ultra only so we'll see if
this new display is a more efficient or
not this is of course just the first
look though it's not the full review so
we'll have to see if that pans out as i
actually get to use the phone by the way
if you enjoy these quick first looks
these short first impressions videos
then there's a really good chance you'll
enjoy this video's sponsor morning brew
so of course i'm trying to keep you all
up to date with these videos but
morningbrew is a free daily newsletter
that gets delivered right to your inbox
that keeps you up to speed on the tech
and finance and business world in a
quick five-minute read so you'll for
sure hear about new phones like this
getting announced on morning brew but
you also hear about the company behind
it and the dynamics of the competition
and all the other biggest stories in the
industry for sure and it's not the
normal like boring dry news language
it's actually pretty funny and witty and
informative at the same time so if
you're interested in business finance or
tech like i am it's completely free and
it takes 15 seconds to subscribe you can
go to morningbrew.com mkbhd and then
you're in there so okay s22 and s22 plus
are clearly pretty similar to the s21s
from last year a little bit smaller and
boxier but generally the same form
factors with a spec bump so the new
specs are a snapdragon 8 gen 1 or a new
4 nanometer exynos chip in some regions
and all specs have eight gigs of ram
with either 128 or 256 gigs of storage
again that's it and then the new cameras
are also a spec bump there's a new
triple camera layout 50 megapixel main
camera that's probably binning to 12 and
a half megapixels then an ultra wide and
a 3x telephoto camera the big change is
that the high resolution camera is the
main camera not the telephoto so you
might remember last year when shooting
8k video you had to crop into the
telephoto this time for shooting 8k
video it can use the main camera which
is going to have that wider normal field
of view smaller detail for some but
that's a big improvement for me then the
other one thing to note is since the
phones did get a bit smaller the
batteries also did get smaller from last
year the plus goes from 4 800 to 4 500
milliamp hours and the s22 goes from 4
000 to 3 700 milliamp hours that's
really interesting i mean the camera
bumps aren't noticeably bigger i don't
know if the glass is much thicker than
the plastic used to be so i'm not really
sure of the reason but whatever it is
you know an eight percent smaller
battery something like that is something
to keep an eye on for sure even if the
display is a bit more efficient we'll
have to test that but that's it as far
as spec upgrades from last year like i
said not a super long list but if you're
interested in these phones which you
really want to know is the difference
between the s22 and s22 plus so here is
the entire official list first of all
they're different size phones so the
same resolution display 1080p but of
course a 6.6 inch larger one on the s22
plus and then the plus supports a faster
45 watt charging while the s22 only
supports 25 watts no charger in the box
for either of them but that's good to
know and the plus has ultra wide band
and wi-fi 6e support while the s22
doesn't just has normal wi-fi 6 and then
larger battery in the bigger phone 4 500
milliamp hours over 3700 s22 plus
999 s22
7.99 so yeah let me know what you want
to see
in a full review of these phones once i
actually get more than an hour to play
with them i think one ui 4.1 is one of
the interesting things about this phone
obviously i saw there's a new messages
app a default that appears to look just
like the google messages app i want to
look more into that but if you have
questions about the battery life that
could be concerned the displays let me
know in the comments section i'll hang
out there that'll inform the full review
get subscribed to see it make sure you
hit that red button if you haven't
already alright that's it thanks for
watching catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]